oh my gosh I have to say too God you
walked in today and I just saw what you
were wearing you walked in I was like
and then you walked out today like in
this and I was like oh my gosh you have
you always been into fashion yes is it
just natural for you well no speaking of
the church you know the black church is
a fashion show yeah and I'm first
generation post Civil Rights Movement so
you know I was taught that the first
impression uh is what you look like so
you must dress up I came from the you
dress up in suits I wore a suit to
school I a jacket and a tie to public
high school you know dress for the job
you want not the one you have was what
my great a Dorothy told me so you know
there were lots of combinations of that
and then I've been able to now
use uh my fashion sense as activism yeah
I like that make a political statement
as well yeah and do you I feel like
every time I see you like on a red
carpet like literally you are a
walking fashion but also SL political
statement there's always something
happening that that's deeper and I love
that always dual yeah yeah and that's on
purpose it's always on purpose
everything I do is intentional okay I
love everything I do is on purpose yeah
you know and because I've lived long
enough I've been in this business for 35
years I made the decision that what I
wanted to do as an artist was to use my
art to heal oh yeah of course my art art
is healing because it's so healing for
us it's heal and I want to share that
yeah yeah I just saw those
pictures I want to bring up the
inspiration like your inspiration with
the with the fashion you've used I want
to bring up those pictures once again
this I remember this first one I think
were you at the Oscars right there yes
the Oscars the Oscars was really where
it's where it popped off there was a
Golden Globe before that which was my
first time on a major red carpet yeah
but when the Oscars called I knew you
know this is the entertainment Super
Bowl my friend Adena Manzel a few years
prior um you know her name was said
wrong and I saw twet we all saw Adele
deine and then she became a household
name because of that and the businessman
inside of me was like well what when ABC
called to ask me to be on the red carpet
I said well what is my what is my wrong
name calling going to be like what is
that yeah what will be memorable also
have a message like I when I saw that
dress I was like well hell I'd wear that
like I I love that yes and my thought
was you know because I used to always
say when I was in at carneg in drama
school we would have Oscar parties and I
would be like I'm I'm not going to wear
that penguin suit I'mma wear I'mma wear
a gown I'm going wear a gown and it's
interesting because words do have power
yeah even when you're not conscious of
it so 30 years later 25 years later
whatever I'm asked to do this thing and
I was like oh I remember I said I was
going to wear a gown to the Oscars and
so I got to Christian Serano and I
thought well if it starts if it's if the
shot starts here and it looks like just
a traditional tuxedo and then when you
pull out it's a full gag I know it'll
change the world because there's more
than just the top you know what I'm
saying there's more to to a person than
even one outfit I love it I'm not I'm
not that into fashion that's why I love
watching it because I don't innately go
I am like the person you hate I wear
like workout clothes every day and I
don't work out on
them that's like look they're
comfortable practical I am 100%
athleisure you have two children I know
and and is cool now I would love to
blame it on the children I was this on
tour before yeah I've always been this
person but I love watching it you know
I'm not a painter but I love art like I
love I love all of that but I I have to
ask too like have you always had like
cuz I get so jealous of such distinct
voices I feel like I have a good voice
but I it's not distinct I'm a no no I
feel like my gift I feel like my gift is
I can be a chameleon I like going you
can be and you have your own distinct
know about that but I love but like your
voice like these certain level of just
like rasp and Beauty to a voice that I'm
like have you always had
that was it ever different or did you
just smoke likeed it was different
earlier okay my voice when I was young
was pristine and clear like aoir boy and
really high but like Jennifer Hudson as
a choir boy yeah like I was a high
belting
soprano like belt belt belt and then in
2 right after
911 I got severe acid
reflux and my voice went away for
about three or four years oh yeah it was
horrible oh my God em one of the worst
times of my life it was the wor one of
the worst times of my life and uh my
voice teacher Joan later and my doctors
and everybody you know really came
together and took care of me yeah and a
new voice emerged yeah and I've leaned
into it oh I love it and I love my new
voice and everybody else seems to love
the rasp too yeah CU have
ears his new album is called black Mona
Lisa I love the album title where did
that come from okay so we were record we
were writing the album I was doing a lot
of writing with Justin transer know I
and um the team was all in there and
we're like 6 months in and um I don't
remember where the title came from but
it just showed up black Mona Lisa and
like the whole room and look at that art
oh my God yeah the whole room froze and
I was like oh my God oh my God oh my God
and then like 20 minutes later we had
written the song and what I love about
it and what it means for me because this
album is so personal and it's the first
it's my fifth album and it's the first
one where I've written everything one
song All Original it's a pop album I've
written all but one song and everything
is from the depths of my soul I have
lived a life and I get to talk about
that life through the original gift
which is my voice and so you know
conceptually the Mona
Lisa is relevant past present will be
and forever more yeah it's classic so
I'm saying that about myself I'm
claiming that about myself you have to
speak life to yeah you have to know that
about yourself and feel that about
yourself if somebody else is going to
see it correct so I'm I'm learning to
speak life into myself which is
important right because if you if one
can't sit in the
fullness of their purpose then we don't
know how to show up properly oh wow I
love you know what I mean yes I do and
it's hard because you know we live in a
space where uh so many people have
opinions about stuff and when you know
who you are yeah and you can speak about
that power very often you're labeled as
arrogant or narcissistic yeah right and
that's not the case there's a difference
there's a fine line but there is a
difference and I have in in the last few
years been able to find that power in my
in my life in art and work and
everything I had a advice um go
ahead was I had um somebody advice um a
years and years ago and I loved it
because it was it reminded me of
something you said but it was like take
advice only as advice not gospel
absolutely because you know you know
your truth but it's also great to hear
other people and their ideas but at the
same time like especially with artists
it's like you know who you are deep
inside like and what your purpose is
supposed to be as an artist not to be
like somebody else so I I love that as
well I have to talk about this because I
love these lyrics I'm sometimes I fall
into damaging thoughts right that's a
whole conversation right there um like I
don't deserve all the love I got but
then I take a second just to breathe I
always come back to me what explained
what is that it's very powerful as
a
black queer
man in this
world I have been told for years and the
messaging has
been that I don't
matter we are living in a time right
now we're at the highest
levels of
government
churches
Humanity folks are
dismissing entire groups it's like we're
going backwards it's yeah we're going
backwards again and the power has to
come from inside I you know being a gay
man it's like the the the idea of like
acceptance and tolerance I don't need
your acceptance I don't need your
tolerance I demand demand your respect
for my Humanity like I respect everybody
else's amen and then also when people
start talking about tolerance and
acceptance that's so demeaning to me and
those words because I feel like no no
you should just love them you you can
just love them like who they are also
puts the validation for yourself in
somebody else's hands validate yourself
yeah I don't need anybody else to
validate me I am enough just as I am
yeah I guess I have two questions here
like how do you fight cuz
they're people are being attacked like
on a like you said a government level
law they're trying to pass laws that
literally send us backwards and that is
fearful for me as a mama as well not
only for me in my everyday life but as a
mom raising a boy raising a girl I want
them to grow up in an environment they
can literally be anything they want to
be and that is awesome cuz that is your
purpose how do you how do you keep the
fight for that while also like because
the lgbtq plus is definitely um under
attack and so how do you how do you do
that without because I feel like people
are being like oh they're being you know
aggressive about it or something and
you're fighting for what is just right
like how do you fight for that in your
way well first of
all
respond and don't allow anybody to
police your response yeah there's a
reason why I'm
aggressive you attack me and then I'm
the problem that's called gaslighting oh
I I know it well so we're not doing that
so we're not doing that anymore yeah
we're but the thing that I move the the
thing that grounds me is I'm 54 years
old I came out in 1985 I lived through
the AIDS crisis I
know that love always wins I've seen it
it's a circle of life right yeah so what
we have to do who are the people in the
positions to make the change is
understand that the change has already
happened that's why the push back is so
severe I know but also I don't find it
aggressive to just stand up for
something so sistic as just being able
to be you it's not that's not aggressive
and that's a silencing mechanism from
the other side I see it all the time
whether they use the buzzword of um
politic ization well yes of course it's
politicized you're trying to take my
rights away yeah yes it's political
you're trying to silence me and that is
not going to happen in the art you know
when I because I'm a writer too so
another B buzz word for me is oh it's
too
preachy somebody needs to be preached to
yeah I was going to say because the
world is a mess yeah we're not killing
it we're not killing it but you know
what's so funny I'm going to y'all just
want me to shut up I'm going to come
right I'm going to come well I
understand that well too cuz I'm a woman
but like but but uh exactly yeah I love
that um but um I love that it comes full
circle though like you said the
preaching wasn't for you but I think
that preaching exists in different forms
and you are very good absolutely at um
motivating people why not use that
purpose yeah why not use that passion um
we could talk for hours and probably
will after yeah we will later but let's
let's take another break though Billy's
album is called black Mona Lisa he's
performing a song off of later you got
to check it
[Music]
[Applause]
out thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home